that's where the drama comes from that's
where it gets interesting
and if your bad guy was only driven by
revenge
i've seen that a million times
we had this comment come in on our
channel
in a horror movie only the villain
character matters all the other
characters are expendable most are going
to die anyway
what's your reaction to that
i don't think that's true
if if no one matters they shouldn't be
in the
film if it's only about that villain
then he should be yo-yoing or you know
doing something else that only requires
you know him
i think that you're trying to tell a
story and every character is integral to
that story or they shouldn't be there
maybe that comes from me
working with limited budgets always and
you're constantly saying you know
why is this person here does this person
need to be here because they're going to
impact me and as far as scheduling as
far as the budget
and it helps you hone your screenwriting
skills better too because there's
nothing extraneous about the script
so to say at any stage that none of
these people matter
i think if you're watching
the later
friday the 13th movies if you're
watching the later
freddy movies or the later halloweens
but if you're watching the ones that
they started with
you would not say anybody was extraneous
in those stories
they that's when they were still very
creative and they had spent a lot of
time working on the script and you know
they gave a lot of thought towards it
and it was written with love
and
when you do that when the screenwriter
loves those characters there's no way
they will be creating people that don't
matter
it's no way
how does a villain in a story reflect
the hero
um
oof if you had asked me this a long time
ago
now i say sometimes my villain and my
my
hero are almost one in the same
they have to pursue whatever their goal
is with the same amount of passion i
think that one person learns lessons and
the other person doesn't and
that's ultimately what does in the
villain and the villain has to reflect
whatever it is or i shouldn't say that
villain has reflected but
their goal
has to reflect something that the hero
is trying to work through
so that they can work through there's a
catharsis you know as they go through
this journey
and get to the end and stop this thing
from happening i think that's the way
that it should go but i i think that
they should both
pursue their goals with the same passion
and intensity
because that's what makes for a great
villain i still consider the best
villain to be alan rickman's character
in die hard i think he is the best
villain ever
because his goal
you know is
is the opposite but they're working
towards the same thing which is him and
john mclean it's just that they're going
about it differently
but they're both after this their goals
with the same amount of passion and
intensity and being clever they're both
very clever that's the other thing about
it like both
both of them are trying to one-up the
other one and get one over on the other
and that's what's so compelling about
watching that story
i think it should be the same with with
any movie that you're working on whoever
is your antagonist
should be going after with the same
amount of intensity and passion
they should be almost a mirror
reflection of the of the good guy if
maybe
they made all the wrong decisions in the
past maybe they didn't make that 51
percent that warren buffett talks about
maybe they only made the 49 percent and
they they weren't successful at certain
things
should the antagonist be twice as strong
as the hero
no
i think that
the
villain should always have
an advantage
and most of the time if you if you think
about it if you using
alan rickman's character in in die hard
um
his advantage was that he already knew
what he was trying to accomplish
that was his advantage he knew what he
was trying to accomplish
and because people would say oh well he
had the numbers too he had all these
guys with guns yeah but they didn't know
who they were looking for
and they didn't know where he was
so
that put them put them at a disadvantage
the advantage of the good guy i mean the
bad guy actually had the villain was
that he knew what he was trying to
accomplish and john mcclane had to
figure it out
so i i think you know i don't think he
has to be twice as strong he just needs
to be ahead of the game and the good
guys playing catch up
but you say
in the in the end that the antagonist
doesn't learn any lessons but the the
hero does
so the the antagonist is just
it's just all anger it's all trying to
get revenge
but the hero somehow learns something
the hero has to learn something he
really does uh the villain
i don't think it has to be about anger
i there have been many villains that
have done things
give you an example moon and the stars
my villain isn't a guy who's really
trying to kill everybody as a matter of
fact he's trying to save everyone
he's just going about it in a really bad
way what he started to notice he's been
to the edge of the universe and back
he's been to the beginning of time in
the end and what he's seen is that every
civilization
every leap every technological leap they
make gets them closer and closer to
oblivion
what drives those technological leaps is
hope
hope hope that things can be better hope
that this makes the world a better place
hope that this gets us to here and hope
that this gets us to there and
what we don't account for is what
happens when we
make those very
when we make those mistakes or when
somebody takes what we were using for
hope and they weaponize it
those are the things that don't get
accounted for so what his idea is is to
create a machine
that
it shrinks this olympic
area in the brain so that hope dies
the problem is when hope dies so does
ambition so there's love so this fear so
many other emotions die and what what
happens after that is that
his project showed that success right it
and people had no hope
but then what happened is whether it was
a day later or a month later people
would off themselves
and if they didn't off themselves they
became
something different
and it became very much like the order
of fanu
that he that works with him to do these
things
so
his
goal
is not one that's out of anger it's one
that's out of love
and you find out that it's to save the
people
that he still cares about because he's
seen what happens in the future
so he needs this to work
now
the good guys know if you do this it's
the same as a death sentence because
it's a ticking time bomb for people just
offing themselves just killing
themselves
so he's working just as hard to keep
this guy from succeeding
so i don't i don't think it has to be
anger or hatred or or any of those
things it just has to be a goal that
they really believe in that they are
just
they've given everything there is no
plan b there is only plan a both people
have a plan a
and what do you do when they're just ah
they're about to collide
you know
that's where the drama comes from that's
where it gets interesting and if your
bad guy was only driven by revenge
i've seen that a million times driven by
anger you can beat the anger out of
somebody i've seen it happen a million
times you know get into a boxing ring
and this guy is angry
he won't have all that in three rounds
because he's going to swing for the
fences he'll be exhausted and you can
beat the anger out of him and he'll give
up because that's all he had was anger
so
the most compelling stories come from
the people who really believe in their
goal and they're willing to die for
their goal
what makes the villain fail is their
inability to grow and adapt
because adaptation is survival right and
the good guy figures it out they when
they're beaten and that you know into
the second act when they're beaten
um they have to pick up the pieces
and learn their lesson
and they're like
i still have the same goal
i just got to go about it differently
and
the
bad guy
thinking that he's won already
when he sees the bad guy show up again
what does he do the same exact thing he
did to win last time
and that's why he loses
why is evil important in storytelling
i think it depends on the definition of
evil
i think that
sometimes people
will say evil is like oh they do these
horrible things
like if somebody takes it just as an
example and i'm not defending at all but
let's say they take someone like hitler
right and they say you see all the
horrible things he did
just evil
i go
i think he's despicable
i think the atrocities are evil
but true evil
is doing it just because
that's true evil he didn't do it just
because
he did it because he believed this and
he believed that and he believed this
crazy stuff
and he was like the only way to do it is
to do this to me true evil is something
that is is birthed rotten
and
it has no reason to exist other than to
cause you harm
true evil is terrifying true evil
doesn't need a reason
it just doesn't michael myers did not
need a reason that's what made him so
terrifying
nothing happened to make him stab his
sister and her boyfriend to death
nothing happened
that's scary i think you very rarely
though see true evil in movies because
it's something hard to capture
it's something really hard to capture
people that just do things because
why not
those are the things that i think in in
reality scare the crap out of me
when you hear about this serial killer
who should you ask why did you do this
why not
that's evil that's terrifying
but it's really rarely portrayed
very well in films